I don't know like sometimes about this
I'm I don't know where people stand
anymore on like talking about it like
what's the public consensus I don't
think people many people do talk about
it I don't think anyone that's that's it
right yeah and it's like I yeah I don't
know well the thing I find funny is that
uh the pandemic has kind of like made
people forget that other like this like
other illnesses exist and I don't
actually mean forget but I remember just
like you know going to an anime
convention and like when you get sick if
you get sick now everyone assumes
covered yeah but then I remember that
conflict was a thing even before covert
was a thing yeah like you'd go to an
anime confession you'd go to any
convention you just you just assume
you'd get some kind of illness right
yeah but now I'm just like so paranoid
that every time I'm Ill okay I've just
gotten covered you know yeah I mean in
in Japan like every year around like
november-ish we have this like wave of I
mean this is before covert we used to
have this like wave of influenza that's
just would run rampant in November and
December right and you know it was so
bad in Japan where like now it became
common practice to go get your influenza
shots yeah I haven't for the past two
years I haven't heard anyone who's gone
to get the influenza shot everyone it's
the biggest Baddie of the month right
like it's like covert's the big boy
right now yeah no one cares about it
those other influenzas yo they're the
baders man they're the beta diseases
well I've recently in um other countries
I don't again and we might have a good
or a bad opinion on this I don't know it
depends on you yeah like I think America
just announced why do they say America
uh America just announced that if you
have care of it you no longer need to
self-isolate
yeah I think England announced that as
well which I I don't know if I agree
with that uh I don't agree with that I
mean I feel like if you have any illness
you should it's you know it's just
common cause I mean this is just before
covert as well it's like if you have a
cold don't come to work if you have the
flu don't come to work just like it's
yeah I I don't know like I guess it's
weird it's weird because you're like
maybe but maybe not but oh but yeah I
guess like if you have any illness just
you probably shouldn't expose other
people anyway but I guess it's just like
the the feeling of having someone tell
you that you should stay at home versus
just having the courtesies
where like they just won't give them the
sick day as well where you have like
yeah right so it's kind of like yeah
actually we're very lucky that we can if
I want to sell isolate that's just my
normal working hours yeah so
that yeah it's it's a lot harder but but
then it's also weird that like because
if you say in this day and age if you
caught a cold or you got influenza yeah
you were just out of just common
thinking you would just be like oh I
probably shouldn't come into work or I
probably shouldn't come to school well
like again no because it's like
so why is that when it suddenly gets to
covert it's like you can't tell me what
to do it's weird as well because like
maybe let's say um you're a teacher or
you're gonna get sick every goddamn week
yeah like you're getting because I mean
those kids are dirty they bring up she's
conflu every week man right so it's like
okay I think a lot of teachers I think
even when they're sick they're going to
work a lot of the time unless they're
really really sick but I think if they
have like a flu sound they just go into
work yeah and also yeah like I said
earlier like you not a lot of jobs you
do not allow people and they a lot of
people can't afford to take time off
work which is a big one yeah well that's
true but like I think like in a
situation where now their home working
has become much more of a popular thing
that if you're in a position where you
don't need to expose other people
whatever illness it is you probably just
you know shouldn't shouldn't take that
chance I think that's a that's a good
habit it's it's I think it's a good
habit to promote yeah you know just yeah
don't get don't get other people is that
a hot take I don't know I don't know
then you care for other people what are
her performance but then there's always
that like the covert has that really
[ __ ] annoying part to it where it's
like all right
I I'm I am I feel I am no longer sick I
am totally fine I am still testing
positive do you guys feel comfortable
with me turning out and I'm always like
yeah whatever turn up I don't care yeah
because I'm like I'm I don't live with
anyone I don't interact with anyone who
is elderly or immunocompromised so to me
I'm like if you feel fine I don't care
well I think it's the just the case of I
don't like every case is different yeah
are you still infectious well some
people are some people aren't it's
there's no hard science that says okay
five days in or six days in you aren't
infectious anymore some people might
still be no I know yeah there's like
still like a safety period I guess yeah
I mean I guess it's just like that it's
like the
the placebo kind of feeling of like oh
God isn't coughing everywhere so you
know even though I know that you could
still be infectious but also I'm like
I'm I don't know like if we have [ __ ] to
do and it's really important I'm like
I'll be like gone if you're sick I don't
care get me sick get [ __ ] coughing I
think you're I think you're able to say
that because you're the only one in this
officer yeah yeah
I also like I just haven't got it so I
don't know what's happening I've gotten
to the point now where I've been exposed
so many times and I've never gotten it
yeah so I don't know what the [ __ ] is
happening I just found it funny that
it's it was just like you everyone who
everyone I met at every point during my
trip got covered literally everyone that
was this conspiracy theory going around
that Connor was like the episode
for two months Connor was the alpha
strain
he was the alpha straight like I don't
know like I I'm not trying to be like
irresponsible I'll be like you should do
this too it's like I personally felt I
didn't feel uncomfortable yeah if like
if we had a film trash taste and it was
just the three of us and God was sick I
would be like I'm I'm happy to take the
risk yeah that's on me yeah if Joey is
too that's on Joey yeah yeah I feel like
we can make those decisions it's
reasonable adults right right I don't
know maybe I'm being dumb maybe maybe
I'm [ __ ] crazy I'm sure this I'm sure
there's you know I don't agree with your
stance I don't know what the um normal
thought is in terms of covid yeah
because I don't know what it is anymore
yeah it's like not anymore it's like
when uh when when Aki got care of it
right yeah Joey was like do you guys
feel chill with me coming in even though
I'm testing negative I'm like yeah [ __ ]
yeah come on in you got to do [ __ ] oh
you can't take two weeks off what are we
gonna do can't do anything
but that's because we're on a tight
schedule now bro but like if we were on
our normal schedule would you have said
the same thing probably because I I'd
still be like I I'm if you are testing
positive I don't care I'm like whatever
come in right but I do care
what oh yeah no that's what I'm saying
that's why like I would okay I wanna
yeah let me make that that if I truly
didn't care I wouldn't even take a test
yeah let me make that 100 clear I would
if I was thought I was feeling sick I
would test and then I would ask you guys
are you comfortable with it I would
never just show up yeah I feel like
that's not my decision to make yeah of
course you know because I don't if I'm
sick it's not my call yeah like yeah
it's up to if you guys are coming that's
why like I was just saying if you asked
me or you asked me I'd be like I don't
care right so you don't need to ask me
right just [ __ ] turn up yeah
unless you have like saying your ligma I
mean
I don't know how infectious that is you
know but like yeah I mean I think it's I
think this is promoted I guess like a
good kind of habit of just at least
asking people because like if you're
sick you should ask him yeah because I
swear before common decency yeah I mean
I I think people before just kind of
like just dumped it out yeah and they
felt like they should tough it out you
know and I know a lot of people where
they got they were in a position where
they felt ill but they were like well
you know I kind of should just tough it
up because the mentality is your what
bro why not coming to work why why are
you asking about this you think the
answer should be yes but I feel like the
better mentality is just asking people
are you comfortable with it because I
could be sick because yes uh in my life
before I have got sick from other people
being sick not just this happened before
covert and yes it is annoying you know
so I I think I think in that sense it's
like it's promoted like good habits I
think so yeah definitely yeah I hope I
don't come off as a [ __ ] crazy person
everyone should [ __ ] be sick all the
time
because you know I mean like even in
Japan that got reflected I remember
there was like a report that came out
during the first year of the pandemic uh
where like the rate of influenza in the
first November went down by like 90 or
something yeah it's just because now
people are just used to being all
hygienic so like we definitely yeah like
a lot of definitely a lot of [ __ ] things
happen because of this but also a lot of
like people yeah gain a lot of good
habits no I have not got a conflu yet
and I see that as a [ __ ] positive
exactly I used to get conflu every
single time before the pandemic it was
always the default I am going to an
anime convention I am going to get ill
and there's nothing I can do about it
but now yes people still do get ill
after Anime conventions of course it
doesn't spread as much anymore because
people are carrying around [ __ ] hand
sanitizers but people are at least more
aware of Health than health issues maybe
weaves shower like 10 more I don't know
what the exact number is but I feel like
people shower more now it took a global
pandemic before we used to finally
shower
thank God
we could be proud of that at least yeah
um oh my God yeah I I think that is that
is a positive that people are just more
health conscious and more conscious
about the people around them you know
definitely yeah definitely I think
everyone's become a bit more of a
germaphobe yeah oh yeah like just
because you had to yeah but mailing is
like fine oh my God finally my people my
people I finally see more people like me
yeah mailings finally not as weird as
she used to be still weird but not as
weird